i want to talk about your culinary
endeavors you love to eat
we know that that's hella good
we already know a few of your weird
combos barbecue sauce tastes good on
everything
some of them i don't think is that weird
like the spaghetti and ranch i do that
right yeah girl that's not weird because
she decided she needed to eat so i
really don't think my concoctions are
crazy until i post them and then the
internet
goes crazy i'm just like this is so
regular to me yeah
well the hot cheetos on pizza i've never
heard of that
are you serious girl that's little
snakes well no the spaghetti on ranch
was middle school days for me because
that spaghetti was
ugh and then you had to make it
real good congrats on your billboard
music award nomination
thank you thank you yes you've been an
artist boot camp
you've been perfecting your craft are
you proud of yourself do you ever have
moments where you sit here like
okay girl this is this is it honestly
this is one of those moments because
i've been inside especially with
quarantine
i haven't really been able to grasp
the icy impact yet so i think just by
being here i am having one of those
moments
yeah girl and the impact is real fast
motion
the song honey
the lyrics are everything what inspired
that track well i grew up as an athlete
and i wanted to pay homage
and it's kind of like an ode to all my
female even male athletes out there who
want to win who
are in competition with themselves and
who work hard every day
who just you know will number one ever
be number two so
yeah i think that i just wanted to
create a soundtrack for all my athletes
out there
what i love about it is that no matter
how many people doubted you you keep
coming out with these hits
it's like oh this is another one this
looks good and then it gets stuck in
your head
girl i got a lot more where that came
from
so june is black music month and
if you could describe where we are when
it comes to black music right now
what does black music symbolize i feel
like
black music symbolizes
culture i mean i feel like we're so
influential
and beyond hip hop and beyond rap
you see black music and and rock you see
black music and
um pop and r b so
i just think it goes to show how
talented we are as people
well next week you're going to be
performing on the voice with gwen
stefani
that's going to be fun are you excited
about that i'm so excited that's my girl
me and what's the funny special wigs on
the track
every time i see her she's just a ball
of like great energy
yeah well you know we have a lot of gwen
and blake fans over here have you
been invited to the wedding would you go
if you were invited
yes i would i love you for glenn i gotta
support my girl
i love that okay last question before i
go we're wrapping up aapi um
heritage month you sit in between the
two you're blasian
black and asian what's your message to
the black and asian community about how
to be united
during this time i think we continue to
be united through events through
spreading awareness through
posting through safe event gatherings of
course
following the rules you know if you say
one thing that's not coming for you but
just the more we the more we stand
together and the more we
we continue to just educate those on
who may not know what we go through i
feel like we will continue
to make a change and i was actually
inspired during quarantine to found my
own non-profit organization
called the ice baby foundation and my
grandmother is actually the president
so i think that it's important for me to
use my platform
and my voice to help and make a change
in my communities
what exactly does the foundation do the
foundation will focus on
financial literacy education
single mothers and healthy breakups in
low-income communities
love that will grow i'm so happy for you
have fun on sunday
thank you nice seeing you again nice to
meet you